it's my pleasure today to introduce you
to our first speaker of this series
Kenneth Calvert is associate professor
of history at Hillsdale College and
headmaster at Hillsdale Academy the
private k12 Classical School operated by
the college dr. Calvert holds degrees
from Wheaton College gordon-conwell
Theological Seminary Harvard University
and Miami University of Ohio he teaches
courses on ancient Roman Greek
Mesopotamian and Christian history and
since 2006 he has served on the Allan
Karras coin collection committee dr.
Calvert has won the Emily Daughtery
award for Teaching Excellence and has
been voted professor of the Year by the
senior class at Hillsdale College he is
written on various topics touching on
ancient history and classical education
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to dr. Calvert
thank you it's great to be here good to
see so many of you so many friends good
to see you Margaret Thatcher made a very
important point
she said the Good Samaritan would not
have been able to be the Good Samaritan
if he had not coins if he'd not been
able to gain wealth and therefore be
able to share it and so against those
Marxists that Matt talked about need to
think about that we need to think about
that in 2006
Alwyn Karis very fine man I had a chance
to meet him before his passing from
LaSalle Illinois Alan Karras gave to
Hillsdale College a collection of
several thousand coins of substantial
value and he gave it to us knowing as we
had been in discussion with him talking
to him about this collection he gave it
to us knowing that we would use it for
good we would use it for educational
purposes and indeed the coin collection
has been used at Hillsdale College and a
variety of classes from the classics
department through to the economics
department the collection has also been
used at Hillsdale Academy among my
students at Hillsdale Academy both the
ninth graders or as well as lower school
students can you imagine being a third
and fourth grader holding in your hand a
coin that is 2600 years old you know
it's a great joy to be able to introduce
this coin collection to these young
people and this is the reason why Elwin
Karras gave it to us so that we would
use the collection exactly as Matt
suggested in a way in which the young
people would come to understand the
value of money and the value of coinage
in human history so this is why we are
using the coin collection I'll be
showing you examples of the coin
collection this evening or this
afternoon
today by the way this is the first time
the coin collection has been used at a
CCA so this is its inaugural
introduction
- the CCA program the history of money
of course a very narrow topic that's a
joke narrow topic history of money is a
huge topic and when you look at human
history you look at human culture when
you look at the nature of human beings
we will use anything for money and
indeed we think of money as coins we
think of money as pieces of paper but
really anything that you and I see as
valuable that we can interchange that's
money anything that a community decides
is valuable and is willing to
interchange for a good or for a service
that is money or if a government decides
okay this is our money this is what
we're going to use for commerce that is
money so it can be anything from a chunk
of wood to a piece to a gold coin
whatever we see as valuable now money
has to have value and so through the
centuries and through the millennia
we've seen certain things emerge as more
valuable than others for instance gold
silver bronze precious metals used as
coinage used as money this is the kind
of thing that is highly valuable it's
hard to get ahold of okay it's a
precious metal or a metal that has to be
formed or shaped and it is something
that is durable it has to be durable
you know Aristotle gave a fairly fairly
detailed understanding of what he
thought a coin should be of what
commercial value should be in coinage
and and money trustworthiness it must be
portable
it must be tradable it must have a
certain amount of durability and it must
have a certain amount of value must be
precious for us to be able to use it
consistently and as a community as money
now money began actually in agriculture
in ancient agriculture such words that
you maybe
familiar with for instance shekel or
Talent
these are riff these are types of money
or references to money a talent being
about 75 pounds of gold and silver but
originally these terms went back to the
agricultural world shekel was a weight
of grain in the ancient Near East an
Obol you've heard of scruples right I
have no scruples a scruple goes back to
a weight a weight of value approximately
equivalent to one drop them and or
drachma and you might wonder you know
you heard the word drachma I think you
probably have a drachma is a handful of
Oval's drachma literally means a handful
okay so it's a handful of opals and opal
being actually an iron stick so you see
it goes back to you know when we think
about money we think about these coins
but what you have to understand is when
we when we look at the history of money
it's anything that people saw as
valuable willing to exchange for a good
or for a service in the ancient world
particularly in the Roman world and
we'll look at an example of this the as
was just a chunk of bronze just a chunk
of bronze that people would use to trade
back and forth between themselves so
here is some definition giving us an
idea of money and what this word money
means it goes back to Juno Moneta who is
thus divinity this goddess of Rome who
had her temple on the Mount and it was
there that the Romans forged their coins
struck their coins that was the original
Roman mint in the temple of juno moneda
juno money okay Juno of the Mount of the
mountain and this is where our word
money comes from but you understand that
money is this broadly defined idea of
anything that is valuable to us that we
wish to exchange now let's turn to the
Charis coin collection and take a look
at
some of the things that have been used
down through history as means of
exchange and the first one there we go
is from China China Ming Tao knife money
Tao you may be familiar philosophically
means the way but its original meaning
referred to a knife or to a sword and
this is a bronze you might call it a
coin it's not really a coin and in in
the proper sense that we have come to
think of it but it was used as a means
of exchange as a valuable piece of money
used in China now if you look at the
next one this is the Chinese poo money
and a poo is a spade usually a large
Spade used in agriculture used by
farmers and what I want to point out to
you in both of these early coins both in
the towel money as well as in the poo
money both are tools coming from their
agricultural roots coming from
agricultural activity and this is
important to understand that most of
humanity and these cultures whether it's
in China or India or in the
Mediterranean region when they're using
money when they're creating a metallic
form of money quite often this money is
taking on the form of things that
they're using as trading items as money
already and in China they were using
farm implements agricultural implements
in their trade in their exchange it took
hundreds of years by the way in China
and took hundreds of years in the
Mediterranean region for people to move
from agricultural exchange from the
exchange of grain of cattle that kind of
thing to the exchange of metallic money
it took them time to gain confidence in
that and that is important for us to
understand in in many of these ancient
cultures they viewed trade and commerce
as something lesser than themselves
you see they're working in the dirt
they're working as agrarians growing
grain and animals how can something
valuable be this little chunk of metal
all right so this is something that you
see this growing in confidence if you
look at the greek historian he see it
he's not in favor of trade if you look
at the early romans they don't like
trade if you go out on the sea and trade
that's a bad thing even in the old
testament among the hebrews there's a
suspicion of trade so it took a while
for human beings through history to take
on any kind of confidence in these
chunks of metal here is a a roman as
from the 3rd century bc used as money
just crude chunk of bronze used as money
in the ancient world so these are some
of our first examples of money now when
we think of money of course we think of
those nice little coins with George
Washington and Abraham Lincoln and such
on our coins and that's what we think of
as money or you know these these pieces
of paper you know we've even gone so far
as to think that a piece of paper has
value
right now the ancients would have looked
at that and they would have you know
been a little bit suspicious of that and
we'll talk about paper money and fiat
money as we go along but the Roman
earliest Rome and coinage were these
rude chunks of of bronze coins as we
have come to know them really came into
existence and around the 7th century BC
and here we have one of the first
examples of coinage this is from Lydia
look at the date 652 561 BC it's a real
joy by the way as a professor to
introduce a coin like this to my
students and to introduce a coin like
this to our young people at the academy
and they look at a electrum stator a
coin from the 7th century BC in
Lydia it's really fun to be able to
introduce kids to this kind of thing
you'll see on the obverse which is the
head of the coin the head of a lion and
this is the symbol of the royal house of
Lydia on the other side is just simply
the hole in the back or the the
impression on the back that is made when
this coin was struck some of you may not
know what electrum is electrum is a
naturally occurring alloy of silver and
gold and so the the the royal household
of Lydia producing some of us our
earliest known coins understand that
coinage began in part directed by royal
Imperial monarchical governments in
order to pay for their debts to pay for
their military exercises to pay for
their their naval forces this kind of
thing but coins also are beginning to
take on in the 7th century and following
throughout the Greek world beginning to
take on their role in a commercial world
very very important for us to remember a
writer Neil Ferguson talks about the
fact that coins once they begin to be
used and once they begin to be minted
transform civilization in fact Neil
Ferguson argues as does Christopher how
gag argues that without coinage without
coinage we would never have had
advancements in civilization met is
something we need to remember let's take
a look at another coin this is from the
city of a Jena in on the island of
Aegina south of Athens south of the
Greek
south of the Athenian City on an island
a Gina this is a drop 'm or a drachma
it is a silver coin you see on it a
turtle and you may notice that this is a
sea turtle very very specific kind of
turtle and what I want you to notice
about this coin and about what a Gina is
saying about itself a Gina is a very
important sea power it's involved in
trade it's involved in naval activities
in the Aegean a Gina is talking about
itself as kind of this shelled defensive
beast in the sea the sea turtle it is
able to defend itself it is able to to
be a presence to act as a presence in in
the sea at sea a Gina is going to be
conquered later on by Athens and Athens
when it conquers a Gina makes them
change their turtle from a sea turtle to
a land turtle and I do wish that in our
collection we had a land turtle from a
Gina as well because there is a clear
and distinct change Athens is telling a
Gina you're no longer that sea turtle
you now belong to us and you're a land
turtle now right but what we want to see
here is a Gina is its own city-state
it's ruled by an oligarchy most of its
history but it is very much involved in
trade very much involved in Commerce and
it mints its own coins so here you have
a city-state
that is independent of monarchy it has a
different sort of government its minting
its own coins and it's involved in a
period of Greek history 800 to 500 BC
called the archaic age in which all of
these Greek city-states around the
Aegean and in the Mediterranean are in
open competition with
another there's one period in Greek
history in world history in which we can
point to and say look here is where free
trade transformed the world and that is
in the archaic age eight hundred to five
hundred when all of these Greek
city-states were competing with one
another and creating massive amounts of
wealth and out of that comes the
invention of Greek philosophy out of
that comes the invention of Greek
science Greek literature out of that
comes the the whole pursuit of of
political science the idea is that the
citizens don't necessarily have to live
under a monarch anymore what other kinds
of governments are we going to consider
and why are they able even to consider
other forms of government it's because
of the massive amounts of wealth are
beginning to develop and the fact that
the everyday average person could
actually put wealth in his purse wealth
in his pocket and everyday Athenian or
from a jeanna a genie in' an everyday
guy could have in his bag a particular
coin it may not be victory
it may be Jupiter himself Jupiter also
drove a four-horse chariot if you ever
go to Venice you should go to Venice
sometime you'll see four bronze horses
up on st. Mark's Cathedral the original
four bronze horses were taken from
Constantinople and they got ended up in
Constantinople from Rome
those were the bronze horses of of money
more wealth than an aristocrat who has
thousands of acres of land it is a
complete transition a complete
transition in the perspective on wealth
a complete transition on the
possibilities that wealth allows or
gives to human beings it is a whole new
world this wonderful piece is from
Athens
I want you to notice what the Athenians
are saying about themselves remember
that point from a Gina had the turtle
this point has on the obverse or the
head side the head of Athena their
goddess on the reverse or on what we
would call the tail side an owl and the
word I they are Athens is on there now
it may look like the Owls mouth is
because open actually there was a cut
made in that coin by someone down
through the ages to make sure that it
was genuinely silver and so that is
actually a cut by someone who is testing
the coin to make sure it's silver
but look what Athens is saying about
itself it is under the authority of
their goddess Athena and on the back is
the symbol of Athena the the owl okay
that is her symbol she is the goddess of
wisdom and of war the owl the old wise
owl how do we get that idea that comes
from Athena alright these coins were
called owls and because the Athenians at
the time that these coins were struck in
the 5th century from 499 to 417 because
the Athenians created such pure coins in
terms of their quality the content of
silver the-the-the-the there's very
little base alloy used in these coins
these coins were popular throughout the
Mediterranean world everybody wanted
al's and so this is one reason why a
thens rose to power was because she used
at this point fairly trustworthy coinage
used very little base metal in her
coinage and so Athens this date by the
way 499 to 417 if you know your Greek
history for 99 the Ionian rebellion
Athens is helping Ionian city-states
against the Persian Empire for 99 years
later darius invades greece and is
defeated at the Battle of Marathon ten
years later in 480 Xerxes invades Greece
and is too
at the Battle of Salamis you know when
you look at a coin like this and you
realize that this coin was being
exchanged in commerce in fact
Themistocles may have held this coin
himself may have used it to buy a loaf
of bread or something who knows what but
this coin was present in the midst of
all of that great history just a
wonderful wonderful sense of history
that these coins bring but in terms of
the history of coinage understand that
this point represents a purity a sense
of responsibility and of good market
value the Athenians knew that if they
produced a good coin a good solid silver
coin that it was going to be worthy of
use and and it became worthy of use
throughout the Mediterranean a very very
popular coin again recognized - as I
mentioned before their sense of what
they're about you know in the ancient
world they did not have radio right they
didn't have newspapers they had no way
to express to each other they're
essential convictions or values they're
consider they're essential perspectives
on life they didn't have any way to do
that the way they did it because almost
everyone would handle a coin at some
point was to put their essential
messages they're essential convictions
on their coins do you see that to
understand that that if you look at a
coin and you are illiterate and most of
the world at this point is illiterate
maybe five to ten percent literacy rate
if most of your population is illiterate
they know what their essential
convictions or values are by their coins
this is a very very important means of
communication now compare this to this
next coin Alexander the Great by the way
this is a wonderful coin as well it
doesn't come out as well in the
photograph as I would have liked but it
is a very very nice coin
attached' Rock'em worth four drops or 24
obols you know that's four handfuls of
ovals this is a silvered Rock'em what is
this coin saying about Alexander the
Great's essential perspective his
convictions it is saying first of all
because he is on the obverse that
Alexander is the most important figure
for anyone using this coin on his head
is the Lions skin the Lion of Nemea his
first labour he kills the lion that is
the symbol of Alexander Alexander has
this lions skin excuse me the labors of
Heracles of Hercules Alexander equated
himself with Hercules and so he is
saying by wearing this lion skin this
first labour of Hercules that he is
equal to Hercules he too is a god man on
the reverse you have Zeus seated on his
throne with the word Alexander the name
Alexander there to the right Zeus
sitting on his throne
Alexander believed and he told everyone
that Zeus was his father that he was a
god man and that Zeus was his father and
so this coin is talking about all of
Alexander's convictions and what his
population his citizens if you can call
them citizens not really citizens what
they should believe about him
compare that with Athens what was the
message there it wasn't about a single
person it was about Athena their goddess
and who they were under her who was it
for the age enums it was their turtle
that was their symbol of unity of who
they were you see there's a difference
here between the free society and its
coinage and the society ruled by the
monarch by the Emperor
each of these coins is expressing a
different political perspective and
Alexander here is making sure that
everyone knows exactly who he is and who
they are in relation to him
so money money is that which is valuable
we interchange it okay as it becomes
coinage and becomes popular throughout a
society it begins to take on messages
messages about the most essential
convictions of those societies let's
move on to the Romans no excuse me okay
I actually accidentally skipped a slide
there and there it is okay as an ancient
historian I'm just coming out of clay
tablets and cuneiform so this kind of
thing scares the living daylights out of
me but anyway on the obverse side on the
face side of this Roman coin
you see Janus the double-headed God the
God of War facing both forward and
backward the temple of Janus is the
temple of war for the Romans and when
the geta the doors of the temple are
open they're at war when they're closed
they are not this coin is minted just
think about this was minted towards the
end of the First Punic War and was being
used in the second Punic War during that
great struggle with Carthage think of
that I don't know if how many of you
have studied Roman history but the Punic
Wars transformed Rome and made Rome into
this powerful force in the central and
western Mediterranean this coin was used
to pay for the military activities of
Rome against the Carthaginians this coin
would have been used during the seven
team here invasion of Hannibal on the
Italian peninsula on the one side it's
Janus on the other side is the quad drag
serious I'm sorry quadriga tiss and the
quadratus is a four-horse chariot driven
usually by victory victory driving this
chariot now this particular coin it may
not be victory
it may be Jupiter himself Jupiter also
drove a four-horse chariot if you ever
go to Venice you should go to Venice
sometime you'll see four bronze horses
up on st. Mark's Cathedral the original
four bronze horses were taken from
Constantinople and they got an ended up
in Constantinople from Rome those were
the bronze horses of Jupiter's chariot
on the capital lion an exciting kind of
thing anyway so you see on the one hot
side the double-headed Jaina
Jupiter's chariot on the capital line an
exciting kind of thing anyway so you see
on the one hot side the double-headed
Janus you see on the others the
four-horse chariot and of course Roma
you get a sense of who the Romans are
saying that the four-horse chariot and
of course Roma you get a sense of who
the Romans are saying that they are
they're dead they are they're dedicated
to their gods
they're dedicated to the success to the
victory of Rome in the name of their
gods right that comes across you cannot
they're dedicated to the success to the
victory of Rome in the name of their
gods right that comes across you cannot
approach that approach this coin without
getting that impression the Republic the
Senate and people of Rome it was a
balance of power it was a approach that
approached this point without getting
that impression the Republic the Senate
and people
of Rome it was a balance of power it was
a free society between three society
between the people of Rome who voted in
assemblies and the Senate who created
their legislation this coin does it have
any human heads on it no it does not
all of Rome who voted in assemblies and
the Senate who created their legislation
this coin does it have any human heads
on it no it does not
oops
oops okay
this corn
this coin is a coin of titus tatius it
is a Seurat a Denarius that means that
it Wayne
there's a coin of titus tatius it is a
Seurat a Denarius that means that it it
intentionally has a serrated edge around
it and these are very unusual coins the
Greeks have originally used these coins
and then the Romans took on this
particular type of coin it's meant at SC
a sunette on the authority of the Senate
and it is a picture of an old say buying
King tatius titus tatius and titus
tatius
unified with Romulus the say binds and
the Romans were at war but titus tatius
agreed to come together and to unite
with Romulus against their common
enemies it was a setting aside of enmity
it was a setting aside of violence so
they might come together 66 BC why are
the Romans minting a coin in 66 BC in
which they are emphasizing this enemy
King this same say mine who came
together to unify with the Romans with
Romulus in 66 BC this is a very very
important moment in the era of the Roman
Republic in the time of the Roman
Republic at this time Pompey
papí the great is at at tooth and nail
is at enmity with another great of it it
intentionally has a serrated edge around
it and these are very unusual coins the
Greeks have originally used these coins
and then the Romans took on this
particular type of coin it's meant @sc
sunette on the authority of the Senate
and it is a picture of an old say vine
king tatius titus tatius and titus
tatius unified with Romulus the savings
and the Romans were at war but titus
tatius agreed to come together and to
unite with Romulus against their common
enemies
it was a setting aside of enmity it was
a setting aside of violence so they
might come together 66 BC why are the
Romans minting a coin in 66 BC in which
they are emphasizing this enemy King
this same say bind who came together to
unify with the Romans with Romulus in 66
BC this is a very very important moment
in the era of the Roman Republic in the
time of the Roman Republic at this time
Pompey papí the great is at at tooth and
nail is at enmity with another great
Roman Roman Crassus and when I say great
Roman I don't necessarily mean great in
the positive sense these men are
fighting over and when I say great Roman
I don't necessarily mean great in the
positive sense these men are fighting
over political power and political
control the Roman Senate created this
point titus tatius in our and political
control the roman senate created this
point titus tatius in order to convert
ER to communicate to the community that
what we're going to do is we're going to
see two enemies come together and to
join as one still a to the community
that what we're going to do is we're
going to see two enemies come together
and to join as
still in the Roman Republic when
Republic still in their coinage they are
producing coins attempting to continue
to convey this idea that they are under
coinage they are producing coins
attempting to continue to convey this
idea that they are under the old
traditional great men of the past and
that they are honoring their gods and
here on the right again victory on the
reverse tional great men of the past and
that they are honoring their gods and
here on the right again victory on the
reverse that attempt to keep these great
dynasts these tyrants at bay that
attempt to keep these great dynasts
these tyrants at bay failed and rising
to power through all of this is Julius
Caesar you see his name on the obverse
on the head Caesar we have to talk about
this coin because this coin was produced
the year that Caesar crossed the Rubicon
he crossed the Rubicon and went to war
against Pompey and went to war against
the Senate of Rome this is the beginning
of the end of the Roman Republic that's
what this point represents and what you
see on this point is not an honoring of
their gods not an honoring of their
great men of the past but an honoring of
one man
Caesar you see the elephant there this
was printed on almost 2 million coins
that year the elephant crushing the
snake it is Caesar the elephant crushing
his end
the Senate and on the back they give it
actually some religious power these are
the tools of the Pontifex Maximus and
that year Julius Caesar was serving as
the pontiff he had the tools of
religious authority so this coin is also
telling anyone who used it not only is
is is Julius Caesar crushing the Senate
and his opponents but he's doing it as
kind of a holy war this is from the time
of actually the Emperor Claudius and
Claudius is looking back he puts on as a
bronze coin a do Pontius a to Pontius
it's a bronze coin on the obverse on the
head it's the head of Augusta Augustus
on the back it's of the divine Augusta
his wife by the time of Claudius both
Augustus and his wife Augusta had been
divinized had been made gods so we have
moved in Roman history from their praise
and honoring of their gods to a period
of upheaval now to a period in which
their emperors their kings are honored
as gods just as Alexander the Great had
portrayed himself the use of coinage in
interpreting and communicating what they
feel is most important move from the
Italian peninsula eastward to Judea this
is a coin of Pontius Pilate a little
point
it shows the Roman control the Roman
influence in Judea you'll notice on this
coin that there are no human heads
Pontius Pilate could not mint a coin
with a human head in Judea because that
would have been seen as paganism okay
and the Jewish population would not have
gone with that and so what our friend
Pontius Pilate did was on the obverse or
on the head side you have that squiggly
line that is a little which is a stick
with a curve at the end which was used
by augers to foretell the future on the
back is a laurel wreath and Pontius
Pilate published these coins so that
they could be used throughout the Jewish
world that litoris used by pagan augers
could also be interpreted as Moses's
staff in Egypt coming out of Egypt
further on down the road in the 6th
century AD you have this coin of
Justinian the first in the Byzantine
Empire again on the obverse on the head
side is the head of Justinian over a
conquered subject on the back is an
angel holding a sword in the right hand
and in the left a world an orb with a
cross in it
showing the conquest and the domination
of Jesus and of Christianity over the
world if we ask ourselves what is this
coin conveying what is is communicating
to its people it is that Justinian on
the top side on the front side he is
ruling over this world and Justinian is
attempting to reconquer much of the
Roman Empire that was lost and on the
back he's doing it in the name of
Christianity so here you have many of
the ancient coins and what the ancient
coins tell us about their time and place
in history about as I have said they're
essential convictions this is a coin
from much later 1808 it is a coin minted
by a private company the Great Britain
East India Company this is a coin meant
to be used
in India and it says in Persian on the
back that it is it is published under
the patronage and of the King and
Parliament of England okay so the
oversight of England of the English East
India Company it is a privately minted
coin but it has all of the messages of
the imperial power in it and what we see
here is the use of this Imperial coinage
in a province of the British Empire and
so the British Empire is reminding those
who are using this coin who is in
control jumping up even further to 1923
this coin is worth two hundred marks
jumping up into history post-world War
one pre-world war ii and the vimar
republic you remember that there was a
huge amount of inflation hyperinflation
in which the national debt eventually by
1923 was just worth less it was
worthless
by the way Elwin Kerris in 1923 traveled
to Germany and was actually in Germany
in the 1920s and that's where part of
his desire to understand coinage and
money began entering into this slide and
into this coin we begin to talk also
about the idea of fiat money and this is
a very complicated subject I'll let
other experts go into it even greater at
a greater level but as early as 1100 AD
fiat money and fiat money being fiat
being the Latin for just let it be it is
money someone says this is money a
government says that a piece of paper
that a coin is money not because it's
backed by any kind of precious metal but
just simply because they say it is this
is not unusual it was used in China more
go polo came across this and was shocked
that the Chinese were using pieces of
paper as money rather than valuable
coins well down into the modern age we
see fiat money used it began really in
the 1870s more and more and certainly by
1971 in this country we abandoned the
idea of having precious metals backing
our money we're now in the era of fiat
money all right
for good or for ill and the management
of that fiat money by the government
either the lack of printing or the over
printing of that money I don't know that
we've law we've learned anything by the
way from the vie Mar Republic looking at
American coinage we have some beautiful
examples in the Cara's coin collection
of of coins this one is a Liberty Head
Gold Liberty head from 1874 you'll
notice that it's a three dollar coin
Abraham Lincoln in 1864 or 65 had
established a three penny coin in this
time in 1870s they had three cent stamps
and so it made sense that they'd have a
three dollar coin if you're going to buy
that many pennies or buy that many
stamps today we kind of look at that as
scan it's a three dollar bill you know
of course we all look at you know Jimmy
Carter's two dollar bill you know with a
little bit of suspicion as well but look
at what this coin is saying about
America first of all it's gold it is
gold it is a precious metal it's not
just a base metal and we're asked to
accept it as money it is a golden coin
it has a Liberty Head an indian princess
on the front of it okay on the back you
have the day to have the United States
of America it is expressing some of the
essential convictions it has a
laurel wreath on the back of the wreath
of victory and by the way you know
there's there's a discussion right now
in Congress regarding what woman is
going to go on the twenty dollar bill
have you are you familiar with that
conversation well all you need to do is
go back to the nineteenth century
because a woman was always on our
coinage and on our bills in the 19th
century it was Lady Liberty and here
this Indian princess is one of the
expressions of Lady Liberty that you
find in the 19th century I'll get to
that in in just a moment
another Liberty Head double eagle with
all the messages that you want on a coin
in America 13 stars here you have a very
interesting Indian Head Eagle Indian
head coin from 1915 you'll notice that
it is incised into the coin okay and
this is the first coin that is incised
okay it doesn't it's not it's it's not a
2d coin it is a coin in which the the
whole inscription is incised and look at
this you have an Indian head again a
symbol of Liberty a symbol of courage we
often think about in the modern day
about the negative use of Native
Americans of Indians in our society well
you know in the coinage Native Americans
were always portrayed as noble as
courageous as an expression of Liberty
on this coin you also have the important
phrase in god we trust'
you began you had coins with in god we
trust'
throughout most of the 19th century into
the 20th century pluribus unum a people
United all of these important messages
of American culture American society
American convictions
19:43 now this isn't the first time that
Abraham Lincoln was put on a coin in
fact Abraham Lincoln was first put on a
coin in 1909 the Lincoln penny George
Washington was put on a quarter in 1932
and you have here again all of the
messages Liberty in god we trust'
a pluribus unum all of the important
messages of a society and however much
we honor Abraham Lincoln and George
Washington I want you to notice that it
is in the Progressive Age of American
history the late 1800s and in the early
1900s that who begins to show up on our
coins presidents men not ideas not
convictions but men and I as a historian
when I look back at the Greeks it was
their goddesses and gods and then
Alexander among the Romans it was their
gods and their ideals and then Caesar
you see the coins send a message about a
society what that society is and what
they're saying about themselves
now here we still have In God We Trust
much to the great chagrin I'm sure of
many progressives on the coin but it is
part of who we are and also a part of
who we are in the modern world that we
begin to see presidents emerging showing
up on our coins not that Abraham Lincoln
is unworthy of great praise of course he
is but on our coins you'll notice that
that coin was made of steel during an
age when the precious metals were
difficult to get a hold of this is a
Missouri one mill sales tax token
introduced
during the Great Depression and used up
until 1961 there were about a dozen
states who used which used sales tax
tokens as money again
the state of Missouri saying this is
money and it being accepted by the
population of Missouri as money able to
be used for transactions money is really
anything that is of value to us think
about the modern age bitcoins a new
electronic form of money and it is
taking on that's taking off it is being
used in East London they have invented a
new form of money called the Brixton
pound and David Bowie that great
virtuous leader of British culture has
recently been put on the Brixton pound
complete with all of his kind of 1970s
makeup we often hear people talk about a
cashless society and I'm one who
believes that that will never happen I
think that we always have to have
something in our hands that we can use
for transaction you know I call up my my
retirement account on the computer
recently I've stopped doing that but
they've kind of begrudging Lee started
to do that again and there are all these
numbers there and I'm told that the
actual cash in circulation among us is
about 30% of the total accounted for
dollars that are in accounts
electronically now that is beyond my
ability to completely comprehend then
I'll allow mr. Forbes who is a genius
and these things explain that better to
us but you know for for human being
for all of us together we are a people
we are a being we are people who want to
exchange we want to to do better for
ourselves we want to do better for our
families we want to do better for our
communities right and so we are always
going to find means of exchange with one
another I want something from you and
I'm willing to give you something
valuable for that you're willing to take
that thing of value and give something
to me very basic it's an essential part
of what and who we human beings are and
we're always going to find ways to do
that now what the history of money also
teaches us is that from the code of
hammurabi
in the 1700s BC to the present day there
are always going to be governmental
powers who are very interested in our
money you know that there are two things
that are very old and human society
prostitution and taxes all right both of
them have to do with money and on the
governmental side it is the idea of a
government always wanting to control the
means of exchange and commerce we see
that in the present day Matt talked
about Carlos Karl Marx even in a Marxist
society huge black markets emerged apart
from the oppressive communist government
because people were going to exchange
with one another be involved in commerce
one another regardless of what the
governments that are dead
we are always about that and what the
history of money teaches us especially
going back to that archaic age of Greece
is the more free we are the greater
Liberty we have to enter into commerce
with one another the more art
the more science the more great ideas
and philosophy the greater societies
that we will produce now is there evil
that comes with money money is the root
of all evil yes if money is your God but
remember what Margaret Thatcher said
that the Good Samaritan would not have
been able to be the Good Samaritan if he
had not coins thank you
are there some questions
technical question
they struck millions of coins yes way
back but what material did you used to
strike those coins okay so in the
striking of coins and actually if on
your way out you pick up a little
pamphlet by Julia Kilgore on the
creation of coins in the Greek and
Hellenistic world it's a very very
interesting little packet and she will
talk about these now sometimes these
coins especially the bronze ones were
cast were the point the the coin of the
bronze poured into casts okay so there's
a casting of coins but then there is the
minting the striking of coins and what
they would have is a the obverse excuse
me the the reverse the tail side on the
bottom
spike okay and then they would have the
the the obverse or the head of the coin
on the obverse spike they would put it
against a semi-soft chunk of metal
silver or gold and they would strike the
coin and that is how the coin was
created was produced and what is
wonderful what's amazing to me some of
these coins that I showed you are just
maybe a quarter of an inch a half an
inch across of tiny how did those
artisans create both the obverse and the
Reavers in such a way as to so
beautifully express you know those
shapes and those symbols on those coins
amazing amazing coins but that's how
they did it and these mints would have
hundreds of people sitting around
striking these coins every day mints as
you can imagine were highly guarded and
anyone who worked in a mint who broke
the rules who tried to steal I mean that
was that was immediate execution okay so
you did not work in a mint unless you
could be highly trusted okay either yes
in ancient Rome when a new government
took over did they have to turn their
coins in for new ones that's an
excellent question barb Babcock she's
she takes a number of my classes and
she's the only student by the way
college students who actually reads
everything I assigned yes mister that's
an excellent question so what they would
do you know when you when you when you
send out coins coins get lost coins get
buried there's a famous image that Jesus
talks about about the widow sweeping her
floor looking for her coin right and
that's an image of God looking for you
that kind of thing so coins get lost and
when there are invasions coins get
buried and the wonderful metal detectors
have helped us to find you know
thousands and thousands of points that
were not known before but apart from
those points that are lost or buried
these imperial powers would call in
their coins as they were able as they
were able to do melt them down and then
recast them with the new message of the
new emperor and remember I talked to you
about Imperial coins and coins of the
ancient world expressing these messages
sometimes people say in the in the
southern regions of Egypt or in the in
the far reaches of Turkey didn't know
that there was a new emperor until the
new coin came along or they didn't know
that there had been three new emperors
in between until you know their coins
came along and say who's that there's a
famous moment in the life of Jesus in
which he says you know whose face is on
that coin and it's it has to be the face
of Tiberius and probably a coin not
minted in Judea but used in commercial
activities in Judea and they say of
course that's that's the Emperor and
give to the Emperor what belongs to the
emperor and to God what belongs to God
other questions yes aye sir so you had
said earlier that there are some
scholars who believe that without the
use of
society could have never progressed as
far as it did correct but what if we had
stayed with a form of money that was
useful as in trade goods instead of
changing to money that was just money
because the government said so would we
have been able to progress the same way
we have now or would that have had a
negative effect on us also right there
there are so many articles and works
that have been done on this very
question and this is an important
question all right
I would I would send you back again to
Neil Ferguson the a sense of
civilization and a sense of money and
civilization so when we are freely and
open openly engaging in trade in the
ancient world its grain its sacks of
grain it's its baskets of grain its
cattle all of that kind of thing two
problems with that it's not portable or
it's very difficult to transport and
then second of all okay in the ancient
world you have this triangle of power
between the monarchy the aristocracy and
the priesthood and they tend to control
the land and the animals and what
coinage does is it means that the
everyday guy like me and like you can
potentially earn enough wealth to be
wealthier than those guys with the land
and with the animals
so the landed aristocracy that controls
the economy and by the way in a
communist state who controls all of the
land the state right therefore you have
no flexibility within an economy even
less so than in an aristocratic world
and so what coins did and what coins
have the potential of doing and minted
money as the potential of doing is to
free up and make
flexible wealth so that Annie Joe auntie
Josephine out there can actually become
wealthy and I'm not just talking about
building a McMansion I'm talking about
just improving your everyday life for
your family for yourself for your
community you know this is important let
me say something else too if you've ever
visited any of the great cathedrals of
Europe do you know that those were not
built by an oppressive Church making
people give them their money if you look
at the windows and you look at how those
buildings were built they were built of
people guilds groups of workers
businesses giving money to build these
magnificent beautiful structures you
know when and and that all happened
began to happen in the twelve hundreds a
period in which the European economy
began to recover and to emerge and
coinage was printed throughout it now
there is always this tension of who is
minting the coins and controlling the
coins and how easily and well are they
accessible and being used and that is
that's a big issue that has to be has to
be gotten at and I hope I think this
week that's going to be part of what we
talk about and understand that once the
government has a monopoly on the minting
of money and coinage it provides
stability but it also provides a level
of control that is going to squash
economic activity thank you
you